لطالما كانت حياة الصياد
قاسية هنا في سان لويس في شمال
السنغال يقاتل من أجل البقاء على
المحيط الأطلسي القاسي
الآن بسبب تغير المناخ ، يدمر البحر
الذي كان دائمًا
مصدر رزقهم وجودهم
وتعيش عائلته في ما تبقى من
منزلهم  نصف مدمر بسبب عاصفة
عاصفة مع العلم جيدًا
أنه يمكن جرف بقية المبنى في أي وقت
ليس لدينا أي مكان نذهب
إليه.  تُعرف جغرافيتها سان لويس
باسم فينيسيا إفريقيا ، وهي
موقع تراث عالمي تابع لليونسكو ، كانت عاصمة
السنغال الآن تواجه استنزافًا بسبب
حالة الطوارئ المناخية العالمية حيث أن
التآكل يؤثر على المباني التاريخية
والأشخاص الذين يسكنون فيها
الصيد هو مهنة  يمتد على مدى
أجيال هنا في سان لويس ، لكن
الآلاف من الصيادين
وعائلاتهم قد نزحوا بالفعل بسبب
الاحتباس الحراري حيث أدى ارتفاع مستويات سطح البحر إلى
تدمير  العديد من المنازل هنا على
الساحل ،
لم يتبق شيء من المكان
الذي وقف فيه منزل الصياد عبد الله توري مرة واحدة ،
يقول إن العديد من الذين فقدوا منازلهم
أصبحوا لاجئين بسبب المناخ ،
وهناك الكثير من الشباب الذين
فروا بالفعل إلى إسبانيا لأنهم
بلا مأوى ، كما يقول.  فقدوا
وظائفهم ، حيث كان العديد منهم ذاهبًا
واضطر الآخرون إلى الانتقال إلى هذا
المخيم الذي يقع على بعد أميال من المحيط ويعيشون في
فقر مع أمل ضئيل في تحسين
ارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر ، مما يشكل تهديدًا
للمناطق الساحلية في جميع أنحاء العالم
مما تسبب بالفعل في زيادة وميض شديد
الفيضانات وعرام العواصف كما هو الحال
في نيويورك ومنطقة نيوجيرسي بعد
إعصار إيدا في
سبتمبر ، يحتاج العالم إلى التصرف بسرعة أو
المخاطرة بالتخلي تمامًا عن بعض
المناطق الساحلية في المستقبل خاصة
في الولايات المتحدة ، كما يقول عالم المناخ
أنس ليفامان الساحل الشرقي بأكمله  الولايات المتحدة
بسبب التغيرات في التيارات
البحرية يرتفع مستوى سطح البحر على
الساحل الشرقي للولايات المتحدة مرتين أسرع من ارتفاعه عالميًا
ما هو خطر  إن إسقاط ous
للعالم هو بالفعل حقيقة قاتمة هنا في
السنغال
حيث المحيط الذي حدد
الحياة في هذا المجتمع لفترة طويلة
يدفعهم الآن إلى مستقبل غير مؤكد